what's next russell well up next have
you all seen the new spider-man movie
hello like the biggest grossing love it
ever well you might want to go back and
see it again because apparently there's
a little easter egg a little something
hidden in there two easter eggs
tom holland
shoot people reports tom holland told
seth meyers that you know that big scene
where he appears with spoiler alert the
past spider-man toby maguire and andrew
garfield well he said one of them was
wearing a fake butt
yes under that spidey suit but tom won't
say
who he says you gotta figure that out
for yourself so there they are now i
have studied this no
[Laughter]
was this your homework
yeah i got to do it well um one of them
do you think it's toby maguire do you
think it's andrew garfield who wore the
speak but fake but under the spidey
costume i don't know but i love that
there is a fake butt
sort of uh
focus like a conspiracy really out there
well again like these are you know when
you need a break from everything
focusing on whose butt in spider-man has
a little
you know
uh extra oomph
that is a subject i could go down a
rabbit hole in yeah you know there's a
lot of news out there and i just chose
to focus on this okay understand and i
think about if i was ever in a
spider-man suit i should say when i'm in
a spider-man suit
would i would i pad anything you know i
mean think about that
yeah i think i would
i wear like a little
chalk strap or what
i would wear you know if i could i would
pad some muscles you know what i mean i
give it i i went straight somewhere else
sorry i saw
well i sometimes i do look at those
suits and think oh it's relatively
smooth i thought that was
a theater when i was a kid though
shakespearean plays who are we kidding
you're relatively nice man we're tights
and it's smooth and it's weird
when you're a man in tights it's so
smooth you don't you don't want a woman
to look at you and say you look
relatively smooth it's not
that's not a compliment i wouldn't go to
the ballet and think
that's weird
am i the only one thinking like this
no you're just the only one saying it
ballet or watch something or a superhero
or any man in tights and not god huh huh
is it just me
well
i want to thank you for being brave
enough to say that true well done i'll
just say what everybody's thinking
[Music]